retrouvez manger ses voté
avec Mutualia la mutuelle des
territoires
[Musique]
ah vous étiez là bonjour
C'est beau la une vue d'en haut j'étais
en train d'admirer depuis son chef-lieu
lent ce beau territoire on a rendez-vous
aujourd'hui avec le sénateur Pierre Jean
verzelen du groupe les indépendants
républics et territoire du Sénat dans
son fief à crécy-sur-seine à quelques
kilomètres mais avant qu'il nous fasse
découvrir son beau département un petit
coup d'œil à la splendeur de l'an la
cathédrale
[Musique]
petit soleil du matin dans lequel se
découpe une grande silhouette on m'a dit
vous êtes grands
c'est très gentil je suis ravi d'être
avec vous avec une tour qui est un tout
petit peu plus grande que vous la tour
de crécy-sur-seine qui a un bâtiment qui
est classé et des années 1500 et là on
est devant votre ancienne mairie je vous
emmène je vous montre les lieux
mais vous savez que maintenant quand on
est sénateur quand on est parlementaire
et plus cumulé et le rôle de
parlementaire et de mère donc je ne suis
plus maire depuis à peu près deux ans et
demi et ça vous manque
un peu oui évidemment mais d'un côté
j'habite toujours Crécy j'y fais mes
courses j'y tourne je vois du monde en
tout cas je suis toujours je vois
toujours les gens quoi voilà cette terre
elle est essentiellement agricole et
vous vous êtes d'une famille
d'agriculteurs alors moi mon père est
agriculteur ma mère est infirmière
l'agriculture c'est d'ailleurs premier
secteur économique axé l'agriculture et
l'agroalimentaire c'est une terre de
passage aussi si on parle de bataille et
si on parle de guerre c'est que c'est
une terre d'invasion c'est souvent
l'histoire qui fait les choses et la
géographie et effectivement on est au
carrefour du Benelux du nord de l'Europe
et de la région parisienne donc on a une
terre de passage alors on dit de vous
que vous étiez un bébé Sarkozy mais vous
étiez gamin j'étais militant et voilà et
c'était l'époque où Nicolas Sarkozy
était ministre de l'intérieur où il se
préparait à la présidentielle de 2007 il
y avait une dynamique très forte à
l'époque et ouais j'ai participé c'était
une excellent souvenir aujourd'hui vous
vous êtes mis un petit peu en marge des
républicains pourquoi je suis devenu
conseiller départemental et un moment je
suis devenu président des maires de
l'Aisne et déjà vous savez quand vous
travaillez avec des gens dans une
commune ou dans des responsabilités
vous comprenez très vite que tout ça est
beaucoup moins binaire que ce qu'on peut
nous expliquer à une époque et puis
quand j'ai participé aux élections
sénatoriales on est allé toquer à la
porte d'aucun mouvement politique
purement dépendante qu'est-ce que ça
vous donne d'être indépendant
aujourd'hui au Sénat
on est dans un groupe à taille humaine
déjà nous sommes à peu près tous des
élus territoire ruraux donc on se
comprend assez bien c'est très familial
et donc on trouve vite sa respiration et
son et son identité il y a pas de
consigne de vote par exemple chacun vote
que veut on a mes conscience c'est l'ADN
du groupe c'est quoi la politique c'est
s'ouvrir aux autres
quand on est jeune pourquoi est-ce qu'on
va Sénat il y a une phrase de l'archer
que j'adore qui me fait beaucoup rire il
dit tout député n'a qu'un rêve être élu
sénateur un jour bon voilà donc j'aurais
sauté cette étape aux élections
sénatoriales une forme de je maîtrise
mon destin vous n'êtes pas dans une
espèce de lessiveuse nationale ou c'est
très compliqué de s'en sortir d'ailleurs
le Sénat on représente les territoires
le mot c'est celui-là et évidemment il y
a une sur-représentation du monde rural
au Sénat ça a du sens parce que
l'Assemblée nationale il y a une
surprétation des territoires urbains
alors Christy c'est à combien de
kilomètres de long entre 15 et 20
parce que moi le matin j'aime bien faire
le marché
[Musique]
quand démarre avec Jean-Marc Le Marais
chez bio du marché de l'an ensuite Laura
à l'Ehpad elle nous propose une séance
épluchage des carottes et des oignons
ensuite Marie-Thérèse et ses fameuses
volailles du Montaigu puis nous
descendrons chez Jean et Philippe
producteur de Maroilles fermier et nous
terminerons avec une coupe de champagne
chez Christophe de la Vallée de la Marne
mais dans l'Aisne
[Musique]
bon c'est un peu le tournant de la
saison mais je vois qu'il y a des plans
là-bas les plans de tomates pour les
gens qui préparent leur jardin on peut
aller voir
les tomates ah bah oui avec leurs
petites fleurs jaunes ça c'est les
cerises
de Berne ah c'est formidable et puis là
c'est glandine Cornu beaucoup maintenant
de jardinerie et danse de grandes
distribution font du plan hein on le
trouve en saison quelle est l'argument
que vous trouvez vous pour vendre vos
plans nous c'est du plan local on n'a
pas la diversité des jardineries non
plus parce que gros moi je fais les
plans que je plante pour moi je fais
certains plans parce que les gens aiment
ça puis c'est tout quoi si je vais voir
Jean-Marc il va me dire attention prends
pas cette tomate chez toi ça manque de
soleil
plutôt de faire différentes variétés et
moins sensible que des variétés comme le
la rose
qui est assez fragile puis ça c'est quoi
ça
tout un tas de poivrons que je fais pour
moi et que les gens ils n'achètent pas
après là c'est du poivron doux des
Landes c'est poivre encore non c'est pas
possible vous avez du du piment d'Anglet
comme on dit du du piment vert doux et
je crois que je vais craquer pour les
piments vers doux c'est combien le plomb
2 euros très bien on va faire affaire
alors voilà quatre et puis deux basilic
ah bah oui
je le garde
oh qu'il est beau celui-là
tu es fier d'être français
alors Pierre-Jean ici on est de retour
dans votre village de Crécy ces
bâtiments c'est la maison de retraite de
la commune ah d'accord l'EHPAD et on va
être accueillis par Laura la directrice
que je vois là-bas bonjour bonjour
bonjour Pierre-Jean bonjour
vous tombez bien c'est l'atelier des
plus chers de légumes
venez voir bonjour tout le monde
regardez la productivité des oignons des
navets des carottes autrement dit
l'esclavage moderne a encore des heures
devant lui y compris chez les plus
anciens non c'est comme à la maison
c'est quotidien ça
hebdomadaire
[Musique]
je vois pratiquement que des dames
et pas beaucoup de messieurs qui est
plus hein
c'est ça il se faufile ici vous le
considérez un peu comme une maison de
familiale
combien de résidents ici 80 et puis on
essaye de faire au maximum en suivant
leur rythme de vie ceux qui veulent par
exemple faire l'atelier plus cher de
légumes il y a l'atelier pliage de linge
aussi pour faire comme à la maison tout
comme pour les légumes les résidents
participent aussi aux plantations c'est
leur maison c'est eux qui décident des
activités qui souhaitent faire dites-moi
leur à combien de temps ça dure environ
cette atelier d'épluchage ça dure entre
une heure ou deux heures tout dépend ce
qui souhaite s'il souhaite arrêter s'ils
ont s'ils ont pas fini parfois ils en
ont beaucoup
ça travaille carrément bien et puis il y
en a qui mangent la moitié des carottes
qui épluent et alors j'ai repéré une
dame là qui a mis l'uniforme des
éplucheuses de carottes
va vous expliquer vous pouvez aller la
voir si vous voulez
bonjour madame vous êtes même Laurent
c'est ça on vous oblige ici à éplucher
des légumes nous oblige ah oui c'est ça
on m'a dit Madame Laurent elle mange la
moitié des carottes qu'elle épluche il y
aurait plus pour les autres la moitié oh
non
moi je trouve ça formidable parce que en
définitive pour vivre vieux en bonne
santé il faut garder un intérêt à des
tâches qui mobilisent la tension une des
ambitions des maisons de retraite c'est
de garder les gens actifs d'avoir une
activité de se concentrer de faire des
choses utiles et c'est cette activité
c'est complètement dans ce sens là
est-ce qu'on peut avoir un couteau
économe pour monsieur le sénateur
je peux voir
[Musique]
faut caresser la carotte c'est pas une
activité que je fais que je fais souvent
tout vous dire mais
ça fait partie quand même des garnitures
aromatiques de la clean française les
plus utilisés parce que ça apporte non
seulement la room mais aussi le sucre
pour ça qu'on l'aime bien d'ailleurs
parce qu'elle est sucrée
[Musique]
un petit peu
en tout cas c'est très beau de couleur
on attend les carottes mais à la machine
[Musique]
la polyculture et le poly-élevage c'est
très traditionnel dans l'Aisne et oui
nous allons sur le mont aigu alors on
compte de la famille marquée qui est
installé depuis 6 générations et c'est
peut-être la dernière
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour monsieur bonjour Vincent
cardio Daniel bonjour Marie-Thérèse
Marquet enchanté
je penserai plutôt qu'on est dans les
Landes parce que c'est du cou nu roux
tout à fait vous avez toujours fait
cette souche là toujours depuis 25 ans
oui on fait cette souche de poulet
d'accord
en élevage et on peut aller les voir
dans l'enclos ah non je suis désolé on
peut pas aller les voir parce que ben on
est depuis quelques semaines on a pu les
remettre en liberté mais on a eu une
restriction
tout à fait et alors monsieur le
sénateur me disait vous êtes en
polyuvage donc les pintades qui sont
tout à fait au fond on entend chanter
lapins qui sont de l'autre côté c'est
vraiment l'opposé et on a aussi une
partie élevage de porc mais c'est pas
sur ce site là
ici dans l'Aisne de polyculture et
polyèle vache c'est assez rare nos jours
un des circuits courts tels que ça
existe ici on produit on découpe sur
place et on vend sur place et quasiment
uniquement sur place et vous êtes en
concurrence on peut en parler quand même
quand vous élevez comme ici en France
vous avez un nombre de normes à
respecter importantes
utile certainement d'autres un peu moins
et vous vous retrouvez en concurrence
avec d'autres produits qui viennent de
l'étranger qui n'ont pas les mêmes
normes et qui donc vendent moins cher ça
c'est tout le problème de l'agriculture
française on est en train doucement et
gentiment de en l'air toute une
activité sur laquelle on était les
meilleurs au monde je vais vous dire
quelque chose c'est pas forcément moins
cher dans les grandes surfaces enfin on
veut faire nos courses comme tout le
monde et on se rend compte que les prix
au kilo ben on n'est pas très mal placé
on est très bien placé
vous aimeriez pouvoir transmettre ce bel
outil tout est-ce que vous êtes aidé
dans ce sens là alors on a fait juste un
farming dating comme un speed dating
mais pour les fermiers
on a contacté la chambre d'agriculture
qui nous a mis sur un fichier je pense
mais bon on a pas du tout de non on se
sent un petit peu etselé dans ce
aujourd'hui la transmission des
exploitations est un vrai problème alors
maintenant si on n'avait pas eu la
diversification il y a longtemps qu'on
ne serait plus là parce que vous avez
pas mis tous vos œufs dans le même
panier si j'ose dire voilà on avait
toujours cette partie agricole mais
heureusement qu'on avait cette partie de
vente directe parce que ben il y a très
longtemps qu'on ne serait plus
agriculteur si je peux me permettre le
problème politique il est encore plus
large que ça dans quasiment tous les
métiers et toute l'année il y a des
difficultés de recrutement pour trouver
du personnel dans des métiers à 35
heures et rémunérer au SMIC en plus donc
quand vous faites 35 heures en trois
jours et que l'équilibre économique faut
se battre pour aller le chercher c'est
d'autant plus compliqué à trouver
aussi je suis désolé mais le département
n'est pas pour
moi je pense nous c'est des clients qui
viennent et qui sont du secteur enfin 35
50 km autour de chez nous on a très très
peu de touristes il y a eu Center Parcs
qui s'est ouvert on s'est dit chouette
on va avoir du monde ça va ouais ça va
donner 4000 personnes par semaine on
voit personne bon c'est toujours un peu
difficile parce que on perd des clients
chaque année malheureusement les
personnes qui sont plus âgées et qui
cuisinent bon maintenant il faut trouver
des solutions pour faire toutes les
personnes qui meurent ne sont pas
remplacées par des consommateurs jeunes
qui s'intéressent à des produits de
qualité c'est surtout qu'il faut
cuisiner nos produits et ça c'est un
problème pour les jeunes des jeunes et
ben c'est un aller-retour la poêle
l'autre jour j'ai un client qui m'a dit
chez moi j'ai pas de cocotte j'ai que
des poils et des casseroles mais si on
met des cuisses à la poêle et puis qu'on
met un couvercle et qu'on laisse mijoter
doucement ça va très bien mais bon c'est
long enfin je veux dire il y a vraiment
un problème de consommation maintenant
c'est vraiment très vite au micro-ondes
les gens prennent plus le temps de
cuisiner c'est plus leur priorités on
fait des cordons bleus voilà ça ça va
vite on fait des lasagnes de volaille on
fait du pâté croûte de poulet pour que
les gens aient déjà la partie qui est
transformée
je vous avoue que ça envoie un petit peu
triste voir ça parce que le métier de
Paysan il est déjà difficile quand tout
va bien mais quand c'est pas qui
transmettre mais je vais vous redonner
espoir on va aller voir Jason un
producteur de Maroilles un jeune qui
vient de s'installer
alors là on est à la pâture de quelle
période à quelle période elles sont dans
les prévoches de mars à novembre
vraiment la saison de printemps été
Jason vous avez quel âge j'ai 27 ans 27
ans et depuis quand est-ce que vous
pratiquez ce métier vraiment de
producteur laitiers et de fabricants de
fromage à la fromagerie ça fait cinq ans
qu'on transforme du lait d'accord mais
vous êtes né là dans ce dans ce troupeau
j'ai envie de dire indique-moi parce que
vous Philippe combien de temps toute
votre vie ici je suis même né ici ah
ouais
génial vous êtes en train de reprendre
l'exploitation c'est ça je suis en train
de m'installer pour de reprendre
totalement et m'installer c'est quoi la
différence il va rentrer dans la société
d'accord ça veut dire que vous vous en
avez pas terminé encore non non non non
si je fais comme mon père il a arrêté à
80 donc ah ouais
après il faudra bien l'aider c'est pas
possible autrement
[Musique]
on peut pas s'en sortir quand on est un
jeune qui démarre
c'est bien de voir des gens comme Jason
qui a 27 ans investi dans un outil de
production ouvre un magasin on aime
souvent regarder le verre à moitié vide
ben faut regarder vers la moitié plein
et Jason il fait complètement partie de
ces gens qui investissent sur le
territoire après il faut savoir qu'on a
eu des années difficiles on a appris du
lait en dent de scie 2009 a été une
catastrophe 2000 2014 une très bonne
année 2015-2016 renouveau une
catastrophe donc gérer une exploitation
et des prix en densis on a voulu un peu
stabilisé l'affaire on a eu l'occasion
de reprendre la fromagerie on l'a fait
quoi évidemment votre lait est produit
sur l'exploitation avec vos vaches pour
autant vous n'avez pas le droit à la
pellation fermière on peut pas dire que
c'est un Maroilles fermier tout
simplement parce que la fromagerie elle
a 10 km de la ferme et dans les textes
la fromagerie doit être atteinte à la
ferme le fait de transporter le lait sur
10 km vous fait perdre l'appellation
fermière alors que la fromagerie était
existante donc c'était dommage de
laisser cette fromagerie là à l'abandon
simplement remis en route et ça change
pas grand chose est-ce que ça vous porte
préjudice de ne pas avoir l'appellation
Maroilles fermier d'accord on vend son
fromage qu'on est face à un grossiste
qui lui cherche à en tirer le meilleur
prix lui ce qui va faire valoir c'est le
fait qu'on soit pas fermé forcément
est-ce que aujourd'hui vous vivez
correctement de votre de votre
exploitation parce que on vit
correctement mais
faut pas faut pas traduire ça sinon le
taux horaire il est pas bon non on sait
bien gentil on cause en cause mais
j'aime bien le goûter Votre Maroilles
moi j'ai pris ce qu'il faut
prévoyant le papa
[Musique]
c'est comme ça merci
est-ce qu'elle mangerait du fromage moi
je pense qu'elle le mange rien
de ta maman je crois que je suis en
train de construire une histoire d'amour
avec la 913
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh c'est beau
tu es pas Pierre-Jean on est sur des
coteaux et ici on fait bien du champagne
on est d'accord là-bas c'est la Marne
qui passe d'accord nous sommes dans le
sud de l'Aisne alors ça c'est trop peu
mais il y a 10 % du champagne français
qui se fait dans l'Aisne ah oui on dit
souvent la Marne la Marne mais mais il y
a laine aussi et donc nous sommes à
Bonneuil et on va rencontrer Christophe
Lefèvre vignerons connus de champagne
bio généralement le champagne il pousse
sur des terres calcaires sur terre mais
moi j'ai plutôt l'impression que c'est
un peu argileux dans le terrain dans une
couche de terre végétale qui est très
faible et le calcaire est tout de suite
il afflel des racines
et du coup plus on monte sur le coteau
plus la couche d'argile s'épaissit et là
en milieu de coton on est vraiment sur
un équilibre calcaire et argile limité
vous avez combien d'hectares moi j'ai 5
hectares ah oui c'est quand même une
belle parcelle c'est bien le gros
problème que moi j'ai rencontré dans ma
vie c'est que j'étais pas viticulteur
donc j'ai créé mon domaine j'ai planté
mes premières vignes j'ai ensuite repris
des vignes en location de la famille et
vous avez agrégé au fur et à mesure et
du coup j'ai aussi acheté des vignes
donc là ça devient très compliqué parce
que les vignes c'est très cher donc
elles appartiennent aux banques pendant
un bon bout de temps voilà voilà ce que
j'ai 57 ans il commence à m'appartenir
mais
voilà ça ça se termine et combien ça
coûte l'hectare ici ça vaut 800000 et 1
million d'euros l'hectare en tout
jusqu'à 1 million d'euros l'hectare
jusqu'à 1 million de résultats vous avez
5 hectares vous êtes millionnaire c'est
ça en gros non mais du coup pour les
jeunes c'est un problème pour
l'accession exactement mon fils il
reprendra le domaine ma fille est
infirmière je leur ai déjà fait des
donations parce que c'est très très
lourd à transmettre il nous faut toute
notre vie professionnelle pour être
propriétaire à la fin de notre carrière
de nos vignes en fait on passe sa vie à
endetter oui on passe toute sa vie à
rembourser des prêts pour acquérir notre
outil de travail donc là mon fils est-ce
qu'il risque de lui arriver d'être
obligé de racheter les vignes que sa
sœur va hériter et là bah lui on va
faire comme moi il va s'endetter jusqu'à
la fin de sa carrière mais bon on aime
notre métier et moi mon moteur c'est pas
l'argent c'est le c'est la qualité de ce
que je fais parce que quand on a quelque
chose qui vaut 800000 € sous les pieds
il faut la respecter un petit peu quand
même et le respect des gens qui
m'entourent et le respect final c'est
mes clients Pierre-Jean c'est une grande
fierté pour les départements de l'Aisne
d'avoir une bouteille sur 10 du
champagne qui est ici mais alors c'est
une fierté c'est une identité c'est très
agréable à voir mais en plus de ça c'est
tout un monde économique ce sont les
vignerons ce sont tous les
sous-traitants tous ceux étudiants et
autres qui participent au vendanges donc
sur le plan économique c'est aussi un
moteur pour le département Christophe
viticulteur vigneront commercial je vais
ajouter un quatrième métier sommelier
parce que moi je voudrais bien
maintenant et ben on y va
[Musique]
c'est vraiment une robe d'or profonde
donc là on est 60% meunier 30 Pineau et
10% chardonner
[Musique]
alors une belle mousse
beaucoup de fruits il y a le côté
gourmand du meunier et après avec le
Pineau et le chardon on trouve une
fraîcheur avec un assemblage justement
là très précis de 40 % de haute couteau
de terre d'argile quoi et donc
Christophe c'est un beau pressoir
vertical là que vous avez ah là là c'est
pressoir là ne se fabrique plus est
passé au pneumatiques ou hydraulique
mais ça c'est vraiment le pressoir
traditionnel ce sénateur l'heure du
dîner arrive et le chef nous attend on
termine la coupe et on y va ah bah bien
sûr merci en tout cas
[Musique]
à mon tour de vous emmener quelque part
un endroit que vous connaissez
certainement déjà le château de
Courcelles je connais une réputation et
j'ai eu la chance de venir une fois
aujourd'hui on va travailler un petit
peu vous et moi on va aller rencontrer
le chef Lucas Vanier qui nous attend sur
le pare-vue merci de nous accueillir
dans votre beau château alors j'ai
prévenu monsieur le sénateur que c'est
lui qui mettait le tablier aujourd'hui
c'est ça il va nous aider à cuisiner ça
va très bien ça va protéger votre
chemise alors chef dans l'Aisne
Maroilles vous en mangez souvent sur
Maroilles passer une semaine sans manger
de Maroilles c'est rare
[Musique]
on va faire fondre le Maroilles avec un
peu de crème pour lui donner une bonne
texture donc on fait une crème de
Maroilles c'est ça est-ce qu'on va
l'écrouter sur les côtés et on va garder
les deux faces on va vous laisser faire
ça un écroutez le Maroilles je pense que
pour un gars d'ici
c'est bien ça ou c'est
bien il a pensé à moi monsieur le
sénateur voilà
voilà on peut continuer
pendant que ça fond on va passer à la
canette mon pire Jean l'atelier a pas
été trop difficile écroutage de
Maroilles je m'en suis sorti
honorablement je vous en ai laissé un
peu ouais en plus pour plus sérieusement
on a passé une super journée on a été
oui parce que je me suis aperçu de la
diversité territoriale de votre
département quels sont aujourd'hui les
principaux atouts quand on veut dire
venez découvrir ce beau département on
est un département tout terrain comment
vous dire on n'a pas le lieu juste le
lieu il y a plein de lieux différents
dans le département l'un des
départements tout terrain pour le
tourisme ça c'est un point mais encore
on parle souvent de l'accueil des gens
du Nord je crois que c'est à peu près la
même chose dans l'Aisne vous êtes un peu
les gens du Nord Est entre champagne et
département du Nord enfin il y a ce côté
identitaire du coup ouais ouais et il y
a plusieurs identités je vous disais on
a un département tout-terrain et on a un
département multi-identité le la vie à
Chauny n'est la même qu'à Saint-Quentin
qu'un Château-Thierry voilà et tout ça
ça fait la richesse de ce département
c'est le sénateur quels sont les points
noirs ou les points à améliorer pour
faire venir du monde et pas seulement
les touristes je parle aussi de ceux qui
voudraient s'installer dans votre beau
département on est un département laine
qui fait qui est en compétition avec
d'autres on est à 150 km de Paris quand
la grande banlieue tiendra plus on ira
chercher ailleurs les entreprises
viendront s'implanter et ben on est en
compétition avec les autres il faut
donner qu'on ait les conditions pour que
les gens viennent s'installer sur des
voies de communication ce sont des
services différenciants et ce sont des
gens qui sont prêts à bosser et tout ça
on l'a allez on va voir on est le chef
alors qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui va
faire monsieur le sénateur là il faut
qu'il termine un peu le plat on va
mettre les cripsy de canette au
compartiment dessus on vient agrémenter
le fromage les croûtons de pain et les
chips d'échalotes très beau tomber des
chalotes
souplesse pour toi on goûte alors on a
le droit
[Musique]
c'est un peu la tartiflette axonnaise
les pommes de terre en moins qu'on
pourrait mettre d'ailleurs bien sûr et
on peut même utiliser la croûte de tout
à l'heure avec les pommes de terre pour
le faire gratiner comme ça n'a pas de
perte il faut le chef c'est crémeux
c'est onctueux c'est goûteux et à la
fois doux
onctueux et croustillant exactement
comme notre mission mangeait ses beautés
que vous trouverez bientôt sur Public
Sénat autrement celle-ci vous pouvez la
retrouver sur la plateforme
publicitaire.fr
[Musique]
c'était manger ses voté avec Mutualia la
mutuelle des territoires
[Musique]